[Music]
we have seen how sound propagates
through a medium when the object
vibrates it creates the disturbance in
the surrounding medium and this
disturbance is what we call us sound
waves the wave travels in the medium in
the form of compressions and
rarefactions but in which direction do
the particles of the medium vibrate
before we answer that question we will
talk about longitudinal waves what are
longitudinal waves let me tell you the
fancy definition first waves in which
the particles of a medium vibrate in a
direction parallel or antiparallel to
the direction of energy transport are
called longitudinal waves what does that
mean before we get to the statement do
you remember what parallel and
antiparallel mean parallel would be two
vectors like this and anti parallel will
be two vectors like this parallel button
opposite direction now coming back to
the statement it means that if the Rays
travels in this direction then the
particles of the medium also moved to
and fro along this direction only so the
displacement of particles is parallel or
antiparallel to the direction of the
propagation of wave is Soundwave a
longitudinal wave take this example and
try to find out yes sound waves are
indeed longitudinal waves we see this in
this example that the particles of the
medium are vibrating in the direction of
propagation of waves sound waves are
also called
pressure waves can you tell me why it is
because the sound wave consists of the
repeating pattern of high pressure
regions called compressions and low
pressure regions called rarefactions
through the medium but wait hold on are
there waves in which the displacement of
particles of the medium is not in the
direction of propagation of the wave
the answer is yes let's see one example
in which the propagation of the
particles is perpendicular to the
direction of propagation of the wave
take a string with one end fixed to the
wall this end is fixed at the wall here
and this one is in your hand we see a
wave when we give the string an upward
jerk from this end what do you notice
here in what direction are the particles
of the string moving up and down right
and what about the direction of the
propagation of the wave it's moving to
the right let me repeat at once the
particles in the string are moving up
and down while the direction of
propagation of the wave is towards the
right the particles are vibrating in a
direction perpendicular to the direction
of the wave such waves are called
transverse waves so are sound waves
transverse waves the answer is no and
it's because the particles of the medium
are vibrating in the direction of
propagation of wave here is a quick
recap of what we did today we saw that
longitudinal waves are the waves in
which particles of the medium vibrate in
a direction parallel to the direction of
motion sound waves are longitudinal
waves sound propagates through the
medium in the form of high pressure and
low pressure regions
hence sound waves are also called
pressure waves and at the end we saw
what transverse waves mean they are
waves in which particles vibrate at
right angles to the direction of its
propagation in the next video we will
understand more about the propagation of
sound waves
see you day
[Music]